all right I want to start today with yet
another reminder based on a new study
that gun violence is dramatically worse
in red States one of the big narratives
that is going to play a significant role
in the 2024 election is that a violent
crime and murder and guns and
Republicans pointing to so-called
Democrat cities and suggesting that
Urban progressives I guess are
responsible for violence and gun
violence and crime this is very much not
true there's a really good piece in
Politico magazine called gun violence is
actually worse in red States it's not
even close and it looks at this issue in
a number of different ways and one of
the findings of the study
is that gun deaths are far less common
in the New York City area than in the
U.S overall debunking one of the very
often repeated claims from the right
that New York City is some kind of
dangerous hellhole and the article
explains that if you grew up in the coal
mining region of eastern Pennsylvania
your chance of dying of a gunshot is
about half if you grew up in the coal
fields of West Virginia similar regions
relatively Rural and relatively
conservative but you have stricter gun
laws in blue Pennsylvania than in Red
West Virginia and you're much less
likely to die of a gunshot and as you
read the article whether you divide the
country up regionally or state to state
you find that historically and presently
blue areas are significantly safer when
it comes to gun violence it's beyond the
scope of this segment to go through the
entire piece with you but it divides the
country up into all sorts of different
areas and looks at this in so many
different ways the Deep South has some
of the highest rates of gun death among
major regions and it's one of the most
conservative parts of the country great
Appalachia has the highest rate of gun
suicides among major regions and that is
a right-wing area and you go on and on
and you find that this is a quite
frankly uh an undeniable reality now one
of the important things to remember
about why this isn't going to convince
the deniers and we'll link to this in
the description to the YouTube video and
I encourage you to look at it and check
it out and you know maybe it will change
some minds but one of the problems with
this issue and I've explained this
before is that number one violence and
crime are genuinely really complicated
issues that can relate to culture but
also economics gun laws access to mental
health services so many different things
this doesn't mean we ignore any one
aspect or focus on only one aspect it
just means it's complicated but the
trend line is that gun violence is much
worse in red States
one of the things that will often happen
is if you say oh the red states are
where the problem is you'll have some
right Wingers come in and say no but if
you look at the red states where the
real problem is is in the blue cities
and of course by sheer numbers it can
sometimes be the case that it is worse
in in cities but when you look at rates
that account for population density it
stops being the case but then if you say
well it's a blue City but all the
violence is in the areas represented by
the conservative City councilors or
whatever the case may be you can zoom in
or out strategically
in order to get the outcome that you
want and that can also make this a
difficult conversation to have but the
big story which is conservatives blaming
blue Democrat cities and urban gun
violence on gangs and Welfare queens and
pretending that this isn't an issue in
Rural and conservative West Virginia or
the right wing deep south or whatever
the case may be is simply not true one
other thing the right loves to talk
about you know Chicago and Baltimore as
these crime-ridden hell holes the truth
is that even within cities that have gun
violence problems the gun violence is
overwhelmingly concentrated in a few
areas most of Chicago most of New York
City most of Baltimore does not actually
have these issues this is aside from
whether
the issues relate to a particular
politics or how it relates to the state
or whatever the case may be even Within
These so-called dangerous cities the
violence is overwhelmingly only in
certain areas and this makes it a really
difficult issue to tease out one
particular cause what we know when it
comes to solving the problem
is that before even you know just on
principled so many on the American right
don't even want to consider the fact
that guns guns and gun availability may
have something to do with it and as I've
said before
let's talk about mental health let's
talk about culture let's talk about
poverty let's talk about education let's
talk about all those things but we can't
exclude guns from the gun problem guns
have to be part of that discussion and
um check out the Politico magazine piece
it's it's very very good Nikki Haley who
is running for the 2024 Republican
Presidential nomination says that it's
not likely Joe Biden will live to the
end of a second term if he gets one now
we actually have information about this
interestingly enough let's listen to
what Nikki Haley said I think there's a
few issues here you know he's announced
his
um you know that he's running again in
2024 and I think that we can all be very
clear and and say with a matter of fact
that if you vote for Joe Biden you
really are counting on a president
Harris because the idea that he would
make it until 86 years old is not
um is not something that I think is
likely it's why I've continued to say we
need to have mental competency tests up
until the day you know starting at 75
just to make sure that these people
deciding our national security deciding
our Economic Policy deciding what
happens to our kids in schools okay all
right you get she once met so for two
different things if her concern is Biden
won't live to 86 what does that have to
do with mental competency it's sort of
like a confused thing but this is the
most interesting part of this the
numbers suggest Nikki Haley is wrong
there are what are called Actuarial
tables which tell you at a certain age
How likely are you to die in the
following year and what is your expected
uh remaining years of life if we look at
the Social Security Actuarial tables
which are for men and women
the left column here is for men an 82
year old man
is expected to live almost seven years
statistically you know it's sort of a
throwaway to Nikki Haley obviously she
has the numbers on her side well she
doesn't
statistically if Joe Biden makes it to
82 and gets elected the expected outcome
is he does live to 86 and finishes the
term now one of the things you have to
understand when you look at these tables
this is sort of it's math that is beyond
the scope of this segment is that when
you add a year of life for example
uh when you go from being 40 to being 41
you've lived a year but you've only lost
about 0.8 years of life expectancy and
part of this is that the longer you live
relatively your life expectancy goes up
obviously not in absolute terms it's not
that you've lived a year and now you're
expected to survive 13 additional months
that would be what some in the longevity
Community call Longevity escape velocity
which is Way Beyond what we're talking
about here but the point here is part of
this is making it to 82 already confers
some idea of health and so you are then
expected to make it to 86 and actually
it would be 88 and something 88.7 even
if that's beyond life expectancy at
Birth this is all beyond what we're
talking about here the point is
isn't it funny when they're clueless as
well as running really stupid campaigns
Nikki Haley making no impact whatsoever
and the best she can seem to do right
now is I wouldn't expect Biden to
survive to the end of a second term not
really a great reason to go and vote for
Nikki
if she's not actually putting out some
kind of policy package that makes any
sense to anybody so Nikki Haley as usual
making a fool out of herself Donald
Trump had a normal one the other day
uncontrollably posting absurd videos to
truth social truth essential this seems
to be the latest thing where Trump is
using truth social almost like a video
blog where anytime something just
happens he has to go and record a video
and post it I'm just going to show you
what was posted within just a few hours
to give you a sense of the way that this
is all working here's a video corruption
at the highest level it was just
revealed that the 51 intelligence
officials who claimed Hunter Biden's
laptop from hell was Russian
disinformation we're not only lying they
were coordinated by the Biden campaign
itself so obsessed with Hunter Biden
recording videos on a whim
to try to go after Hunter Biden
continuing to present no viable policy
package for his presidency it was
corruption at the highest level and it
was a hoax perpetrated by Biden
Secretary of State Anthony blinken and
partisan intelligence officials to cover
up the truth about the Biden crime
family's grotesque influence peddling
and Corruption Okay so
everything he's saying here is false
it's a lie it's made up and again just
recording these videos on a loop moments
later with a video about the fake news
for all of those media fools who say
everything was on the up and up with the
2020 presidential election and then got
on to report about 51 intelligence
agents that wrote a letter spreading
disinformation about Hunter Biden's
famous laptop computer knowing it was
fake and treasonous just days before the
election
you have committed all right I'm not
going to play all of this for you I'm
just giving you a flavor it's
uncontrollable then another video about
who the hell even knows what it turns
out that Joe Biden and the Biden White
House knew everything about the
unconstitutional raid by the FBI and doj
on Mar-A-Lago no evidence that this is
true either right there
unequivocal denial they denied it they
said we know nothing about it we know
absolutely nothing about it we would
never do such a thing
they lied all right so then there's
another again it's just he's doing like
a video blog
um then posting a piece of an interview
from Newsmax but they are very good at
two things disinformation and cheating
on elections that's what they do you saw
that this information with this new
revelation that this was incredible that
51 intelligence agents totally lied I
think it's treason they totally lied
just before the election right before
the vote they lied and they said that
the computer which had all crimes on it
was Russian disinformation the computer
had crimes on it so this is happening
almost 24 hours a day at this point in
time think about where we have gotten in
2023 on the cusp of a major presidential
election a very uh content very much
contested Republican primary you have
Joe Biden
doing things and announcing a
re-election campaign that admittedly
many Americans don't want but he is
functioning as a president accomplishing
things and Donald Trump sits at his
house recording 30 to 50 second video
blogs about conspiracy theories he
either misunderstood
or just as blatantly lying about
that's the contrast that we have
my real hope and I say this as a
non-biden cheerleader if this race comes
down to Biden versus Trump a rematch of
2020 which would be an incredible uh
situation in American history
I hope Trump genuinely gets crushed and
then we can say goodbye to Trump's
political career once and for all that
would really be a delightful outcome if
that that's where this ends up if it
ends up being Marianne Williamson versus
Ron DeSantis okay well then that'll be a
different situation but if it's Biden
Trump if that's the if the rematch
narrative is the one that ends up being
the reality
I want Trump to really get crushed and
to say sayonara to his political career
let's take a quick break we'll be back
with much more right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is a community
supported program this is as good a time
as any to suggest to you that if you'd
like to support the work we do you can
sign up at joinpakman.com it's very
cheap it's very quick and it comes with
great benefits including access to the
Daily bonus show commercial free audio
and video streams of the show and
invitations to member only Town Hall
events very exciting stuff you can sign
up at joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code indicted to get a discount
let's now take some phone calls we're
going to hear from people in the
audience we do this via Discord they're
not really phone calls but sometimes
it's kind of like hard to explain what
they are if I don't say phone calls so I
just call them phone calls but you go to
davidpackman.com
Discord and that's where it's all
happening all right let's go with Adrian
from Wyoming and hear from Adrian first
today Adrian what's going on
hi David I have a question for you about
um what Joe Biden cares about because I
know there's kind of a maxim about if
presidents really care about certain
issues they'll do more and I'm wondering
how you think he's done regarding trans
rights especially in the wake of uh the
potential expulsion of a Montana state
senator today I don't know exactly
what's going on with that I did not see
that story but let me address that you
know here's here's the thing with all of
these issues so often this debate starts
about has the president done enough or
not on a particular issue and then
subsequent to that the question becomes
how much can a president do about that
particular issue and when it comes to
trans issues the unfortunate reality is
that a lot of this stuff is determined
at the state level now you could say
well there should be some overarching
federal law protecting trans people but
we already know from experience with
other issues related to gender and
sexual orientation that that often is
not something that it happens or happens
quickly so I I have to admit I don't
know the full scope of what Biden could
do federally to best evaluate how what
kind of a job he's done if that makes
sense
right and I personally like I'm I'm
right with you there I realize that in a
deadlock Congress there's very little
that's potentially going to get done
especially with the red meat that this
issue unfortunately provides the
Republican base absolutely um I just
think I just wander and uh just wanted
to hear your perspective uh symbolically
like like for when he invited the
Tennessee three over earlier I believe
this week
um and just hosting more events or just
talking a little bit more about those
kind of issues just from that kind of
perspective because I realized
legislatively that he's kind of
deadlocked and not much may get done but
I appreciate your thoughts on well
listen I mean okay so Biden could sign
executive orders and and Direct Federal
departments to uh enact certain policy
protections okay so I don't know that
he's done a ton of that he can use the
bully pulpit to talk about the issue I
think he has I mean he brings up trans
issues at many speeches so I think there
he's doing okay he can appoint officials
in his administration who are Defenders
of trans rights and I think mostly he's
done that he certainly hasn't appointed
anyone I'm aware of who's hostile or
indifferent to trans rights so that's
okay
um and then he can sort of like push
state and local governments to do one
thing or the other but the unfortunate
reality is the state the state
governments that would listen to Biden
are already doing pretty well when it
comes to protecting trans people anyway
and the state governments that are
aggressively persecuting trans people
aren't going to care what Joe Biden says
anyway so you know I think he's doing
okay but he could always do more
yeah I fully agree I am I really
appreciate it um because I know that uh
my ex home my ex state where I went to
college in Minnesota there they took a
big step everyone's either taking big
steps up or big steps back and it's just
very unfortunate to see right now so I
appreciate you taking the call um thanks
for your perspective hope you have a
great day all right thank you there is
Adrian from Wyoming let's go next to
genio from Chester is this Chester
Springs yes genio from Chester Springs
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hi can you hear me yes I can
hi uh Chester Springs Pennsylvania
outside of Philadelphia love it that's
awesome
um I'm surprised I got picked um thank
you um so my question is my first
question is I've always wanted to ask
you a big fan for a long time do you
listen to Howard Stern you know I've
I've been a listener since I was like
age 14 but if I'm totally honest since
the pandemic started I've barely
listened at all
I mean part of it is I I no longer have
serious radio so I know that a bunch of
the like the interviews get posted to
YouTube or whatnot but I don't have
Sirius anymore
I understand I understand well Howard
does wonderful interviews just like you
do that's why I asked because
um I feel like he's one of the best
interviewers and his interviews have
gotten better over the past few years I
agree um and I find that you are a
wonderful interviewer as well so I
thought maybe you had some inspiration I
agree that he's a great interviewer and
I appreciate the compliment but I I have
not had the pleasure of listening much
lately now let me ask you this for a
while he was like down in his house in
Florida doing the show remotely is he
back in the New York Studio
you know what I think he's still
um he's still fully remote he's very
very anxious about kovid and he's like
just getting at like he talks about it
almost on a daily basis he's just
getting out and like meeting friends and
he's still like very worried about it
and um but I I could be wrong but I
think he's still in his studio in the
Hamptons and his studio in Florida Fair
he is but yeah I think he's remote still
but he has like he's had some really
good interviews and that they um when he
has musical guests they go to the
serious studio in New York I believe all
right very good well let's uh let let me
not to take time away from your question
I have one other question
um how do you feel about
um and I might have missed it here and
there about your feelings on Israel and
the Israeli government because as a you
know a Jewish American and I want to
support Israel but I have really hard
feeling I have a hard time supporting
Israel knowing some of the things that
they're doing to Palestinians and I just
wanted to know like what your feelings
on that is I have certainly dozens of
clips about this I mean my view is that
I am a hundred percent opposed to these
right-wing Israeli governments Netanyahu
Etc I'm against illegal settlements I
would like to see the blockade with Gaza
ended and I also recognize that it's
simply not going to end until there are
either certain concessions or assurances
that come from Hamas which is
extraordinarily unlikely and it's it's
such a complicated issue Jenny oh but I
think I'm often attacked as being a
shill for Israel and a lot of that is
unfortunately just because I'm Jewish
and it's disappointing to see that when
it comes to policy
if you look at I've probably done it 10
times now if you look at my policy idea
for how to resolve the conflict I think
it's it's quite fair and both sides
could probably find issue with it but I
think there's one other important thing
one of the things that's unfortunate is
there's a standard applied to Israel
when it comes to quote supporting the
country which might include like even
going on a trip that no one applies to
other countries which I would like to
see change like for example if people
very few people see like for example I
went to England when Boris Johnson was
the Prime Minister I didn't support
Boris Johnson but to say I won't go
there because it's an endorsement of
Johnson I don't agree with that and yet
like when I went to Israel people wrote
to me saying how could you you're
supporting settlements you're supporting
Netanyahu because you're there that is
like never really applied to other
countries and and I would like to see
that applied a little more fairly people
came to the U.S when Trump was President
didn't mean they supported Trump you
know what I'm saying yeah for sure no I
completely agree with you yeah and I
also feel like people because I I you
know we're Jewish people feel like we
have to support Israel and I support
Israel as a country and I support the
people who live there but I don't
support the government just how people
would support the United States but they
never that wouldn't necessarily support
Trump and I'll go further than that
Jenny I'll go even further not only do
Jews not have to do anything in
particular when it comes to supporting
or defending or attacking Israel
um American Jews also have no reason to
even be answering the questions about
Israeli foreign policy I was once at a
brunch a couple years ago and met
someone for the first time and they
started putting me in the position of
having to explain to them about this
that or the other thing about Israel and
it's like I've been there once in my
life I'm from Argentina I've lived in
the the United States the vast majority
of my life I happen to be Jewish but
it's it's kind of weird to put me in a
position of having to defend or explain
anything about Israel ask Israelis you
know yeah that's so so true thank you so
much I really appreciate your response
all right genio from Chester Springs
beautifully asked uh let's see where are
we going next oh remember if you want to
get on your name needs to be name and
location or location and name however
you want to do it in whatever order you
want to do it like for example Connor
from New Jersey is our next caller today
Connor what's going on hi David how are
you oh you already told us not to ask
how you're doing um I I have a question
but I wanted to pass on words of
affirmation for starters please I've
been following you for a little while
now like I honestly solidly since the
Trump arrest was announced and all that
you remember me calling in the day prior
I was like I don't think he's gonna get
arrested but you don't have to remember
okay my whole point is I've been
following you and honestly I I grew up
in like a more Republican conservative
house and I might have those views
honestly I don't even know where I fall
politically but
listening to you I just feel like you
are so well thought out so your
methodology of breaking down issues is
just so solid and I wish that there was
more people that claim to be
conservative or republican that could be
so again well thought out I mean like
you're inspiring to me like I hope that
I could help change the perspective on
conservatism well I appreciate that very
much you know you know move the
Republican Party forward and help open
discussion and not have it be this
close-sided debate between the two
parties I mean I really think it's
possible young people have to say enough
is enough I mean I'm not against trans
people I support gay rights but I still
call myself conservative I really don't
even know what that means at this point
yeah but all I know is I want change I
want people to stop picking sides and
actually have these sides working
together for a bipartisan solution what
issues are you conservative on
I don't really know honestly I think
it's more so of just like how I carry
myself really so I don't know I I to be
fairly honest with you I've just grown
up in an atmosphere that was like that
it sounds like you're sort of culturally
conservative because of your
conservative but politically I might
lean more Democrat or left whatever you
want to call it and um honestly I really
wish that people didn't see how I
carried myself and thought that was how
I carried my political views
interesting at the end of the day I find
you really inspiring and I want to know
how can you uh what can you suggest to
people like me who follow you and want
to help you know bring more discussion
in the world or at least in the United
States when it comes to really stupid
issues that have been around since the
60s well I think it's just engage and
talk to people and share your story and
say Hey you know I kind of defaulted to
a particular world view just by virtue
of where I was born but the more I
examine a lot of these issues I come to
to realize maybe I was wrong about some
of these things and I think that there's
it's really powerful to hear from people
on one's quote side as trite as that may
be and say hey yeah I am from the same
place you are I was raised the same way
but I've been able to actually get some
distance and get some facts and I've
revised my view you can do the same
thing and there's no shame in that I
think that can be very powerful
and I guess one thing I want to ask you
before you get some more people David is
do you like personally I don't think I
should switch to becoming a Democrat I
think I should be trying to help bring
the Republican Party forward even if I
don't vote Republican I think the people
that I'm around I should try to help
open their minds to these discussions
and help it not be so hard for people on
the left if I really empathize with both
these positions
I don't know that it really matters
whether you're registered one way or the
other I mean it's it's I don't think
that that's the most important thing one
way or the your story is still the same
story regardless of you know your party
affiliation I think so just keep doing
me and hope to open more discussion I
guess that's what I would say yeah thank
you David honestly it's been awesome to
listen to this the short while all right
thanks for all right Connor from Jersey
great to hear from you very very
interesting message that's for sure
let's go to Miranda
from where is Miranda from is it San San
Diego so I see essay
Miranda from uh sa Texas okay where is
SA Texas
San Antonio
got beautiful great to have you on
David
Miranda you're on the air but it seems
as though your connection leaves a
little bit to be desired let's see if we
can hear you if you try to say something
can you hear me better yes I can
okay awesome so I wanted to ask you
um what are your thoughts I read an
article recently
um with the local news about Ted Cruz
and how he's basically a shoe-in for his
Senate see it's up for re-election next
year and I just wanted to know if you
how you felt about Ted Cruz and
um basically they're saying there's
really no competitors to that seat and
it's kind of disappointing you know I
did love bet though and I you know did a
bunch of rallies with him and went out
there met him talked to him so many
times and I really wish that he would
run again I don't know if he would win
um because he has lost you know multiple
times but I would love if he ran again I
haven't really heard of anybody else no
so I don't know if you've heard of
anybody or if you have any hopes well I
always have hopes it would always be a
delight to see Ted Cruz defeated you're
correctly assessing that Beto was one of
the toughest Challengers that one could
have in a Texas Race and cruise is up
for re-election next year I've not heard
that Beto is looking at running there's
I can't think of anyone else for whom
there's more enthusiasm and Beto also
was not successful so that is a question
when you say well even someone as
popular and well like this beta was not
able to win is there anyone who could
defeat Ted Cruz I don't know you know
it's a I'm I'm kind of withholding
judgment and we've still got some time
and it would be a great thing but
obviously if I'm totally realistic with
you uh it's it's going to be a tough one
to to win for sure
right yeah and I agree and you know that
reading that article was just kind of
like so disappointing because I don't
understand how he's so you know well
liked in certain areas I mean it just
doesn't make sense I don't understand
how anybody could be for Ted Cruz I mean
I don't really know what he's done for
us but you know I get it everybody has
their people that they like so I'm just
hopeful that maybe Bethel will come
forward and run again or we can soon
hear of somebody you know great running
I'm with you I'm with it would be I mean
I obviously eventually Ted Cruz will no
longer be in the Senate either because
he will die or he will quit or he will
lose
um I would love to see it be because he
loses that would really be a great thing
um but let's see who presents themselves
let's see who shows up to face him in
2024.
thanks so much David I really appreciate
it all right Miranda from San Antonio
great to hear from you let's take the
quickest of quick breaks but if you're
on the phone hang on because I'm going
to get right back to calls in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's get
back to Discord and hear from some more
people in the audience that's
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to James from Southern
California James from Southern
California welcome to the program what
is on your mind today sir
thank you very much David are you able
to hear me okay I can hear you
beautifully
um I want to start by thanking you for
everything you do I really appreciate
all you've done over the years on your
program
um I uh I have a comment and I have a
question sure one comment I want to make
uh regarding the people with the Maga
mentality uh I really want to encourage
everyone to be patient with these folks
because we can get through to them I've
had a lot of success and I think the
approach I use is very important in
remembering that they do live in fear to
some extent they have very much happen
to us in them mentality oh yeah and if
you can establish that you are one of
them and we are us they will listen to
you and as long as you don't tell them
they're wrong but simply give them
information but build from the bottom up
remembering they're they're ignorant
like little children
um and you need to use terms and
Concepts and once you have them on their
your side and they're agreeing with you
you can start correcting the
misinformation that in their head and
help them kind of rebuild their view of
reality I don't disagree with that one
bit
it takes a lot of patience yes and I
really want to encourage people to go
out to friends family members who are
frustrating you and try to approach them
as they are a little child well here's
the thing James everything you're saying
is correct the important thing to
remember is that's like a retail
strategy person by person and it's
insanely time consuming doesn't mean we
don't do it but it is insanely time
consuming we also want to see is there
some wholesale approach that might
deprogram larger numbers of these people
and that's a tougher question to answer
it is indeed but I believe we need to
approach this from the Grassroots
because we all have a friend or family
member that we are probably avoiding
instead we need to help them right we
need to help our community and I think
it's a big part it's on us uh rather
than letting it happen we need to be
patient and take the time and yes it is
time consuming but it does work it can
be done I I have faith in that and I
just wanted to make that comment Fair
because many of us are feeling a little
hopeless but don't give up on it you
know take that stand anyway I have a
question for you sure
um I was wondering what do you think the
uh odds are of Tucker Carlson ending up
on Newsmax
that's a good question you know I I have
I have no idea I don't think I have
anything substantive or objective that I
could say could Tucker Carlson end up on
Newsmax I know the CEO of Newsmax
interestingly enough he's kind of like a
fan of my work interestingly even though
our our political views are very very
different
um he is at heart a business person and
so without a doubt if I had to bet I
would bet that he's looking to see what
could happen maybe with Tucker Carlson
on Newsmax my instinct is that it would
be neither prestigious nor lucrative
enough for for Tucker Carlson
uh to join I think Tucker Carlson would
have more to gain from launching his own
thing from scratch but uh it's not
impossible it's not I don't know where
Tucker is going to end up
yeah I don't either I'm worried about
that I was just wondering about your
take on that well thank you so much
David I really appreciate everything you
do for us my pleasure James from
Southern California very very good to
hear from you why don't we go next to
Bert in New Jersey Bert in New Jersey
welcome to the David Pacman show
okay jumping right in again uh calling
you for another Wednesday we're
pretending to be on work calls so all
right
um I want to ask you um I think it was a
Rolling Stone magazine reported a couple
weeks ago that when Trump got arraigned
he had the option to do it over Zoom for
more Lago and not go into uh Manhattan
I don't know if you heard anything about
this whether that that's true because if
it is that's significant where you know
he complains about New York City
spending all this money and everything
all could have been avoided the circus
could have avoided had he done that I am
not aware that Trump was given the
opportunity to be arraigned via Zoom uh
let's see if I search for that Trump
arraignment via Zoom opportunity
um fact check did Trump refuse
arraignment over Zoom from Mar-A-Lago
um there was a tweet posted about that
what is the verdict
um unnamed sources only and no actual
verified evidence so at this point it is
at best an unverified claim so it I mean
listen either way I've not seen anything
verified that Trump could have stayed at
Mar-A-Lago what I do know is that that
Court was not doing anything over Zoom
for a while now now whether they would
have made a special exception for Trump
maybe but Trump said he wanted the whole
Pomp and Circumstance he wanted to be
handcuffed he wanted a mug shot
supposedly because he thought it would
help him so I don't know if any of
that's true I can't imagine Trump would
have wanted to do it by Zoom
yeah interesting uh thing to follow just
in case that turns out to be true and
now one more question to urge you on the
Patrick fed David podcast yeah I love
that uh you know I thought it was great
it's so such a breath of fresh air to
hear
instead of just a typical cable news
propaganda you have two people with
conflicting ideologies like recognize
each other's logic right it's so
rewarding to hear yeah I mean I don't
know about sometimes there wasn't much
logic I have to tell you Bert but I know
what you're saying at least hearing the
rationale yeah yeah there were instances
where he was forced to kind of Nod his
head and go oh okay you know I I know I
have no rebuttal for that yeah those are
those are critical key moments
um question I have and I think all your
audience members is also wondering too
when are you going to sit down and do
round two with Ben Shapiro because we
would love that we Ben Shapiro hasn't
been on I think for like 10 years we've
invited him multiple times he never
responds and you know he doesn't have
any responsibility to me he's he's way
bigger than I am and he may be just too
busy for me and that's totally fine but
we've invited him a bunch of times it's
up to him when we sit down again not up
to me I'm willing to do it anytime
awesome awesome to hear all right thanks
Bert from Jersey uh all good questions
very important stuff and different
things going on let's go to Marcus from
is it Manitoba
or or mat uh Manitoba yeah Marcus from
Manitoba welcome to the program but sir
yes yes it is from Manitoba in fact
what's on your mind I'm coming to you
yeah yeah and I'm coming to you
with tears in my eyes over this latest
news from Fox News that uh air star
Tucker Carlson has been looted right
here
and I'm wondering just how
it got to the point where this guy
is
was just sort of being given the
platform to
say some of like the most extreme and
even within like the circles of American
conservatism uh
quite unpopular things
like seemingly just without any
reprimand from
the organization he was working for
you're saying how did how was Tucker
able to say the things he said without
being reprimanded by Fox
well I I guess I'm just wondering like
how did Fox News not realize that the
things that Tucker Carlson as well as
you know their other hosts were saying
we're going to get them sued eventually
well it's more complicated than that
because the most of the trouble that
Tucker caused for Fox is not really
related to the things he said yes he
played koi with the Dominion and 2020
election stuff and that was part of the
lawsuit but it was less about what
Tucker himself was necessarily saying
the lawsuit for discrimination from a
staffer former staffer doesn't relate to
what Tucker said on air the potentially
forthcoming lawsuit from rayap's wood
but we'll have to wait and see whether
that's filed so I think it's a little
more complicated than that I mean Fox's
primary concern is ratings and Tucker
had good ratings so that's fundamentally
the most important thing
I guess so yeah that's true but I
suppose more broadly I I'm just kind of
wondering like who Tucker Carlson's
audience is apparently has a huge
audience
um but like the things he was saying
especially about like Russia and Ukraine
it's it's not something that like any of
the other like mainstream well certainly
not mainstream Republicans but even uh
it's not like uh it's it's the he's
taking the Russian position he has said
that he is like pro-putin essentially
yeah he didn't say that but he certainly
made some strange comments about it
listen his audience is is Right Wingers
and there's a desire for this contrarian
sort of Maga style right wing ISM which
often ends up using populist rhetoric
and being a little more deferential to
Global authoritarians than you might
think so in that sense it's not that out
of left field
I guess so
one of my favorite sort of tropes that
you see on the very far right
um you know among uh
people like like Matt Yates and such
which he kind of uh was demonstrated in
that one uh meeting of him in that one
that one clip where he uh used
uh Chinese propaganda
as evidence that the US was funding the
Azog Battalion in Ukraine not realizing
that it was Chinese propaganda and then
it was embarrassed when he was because
like
um or when it was shown to him that it
was Chinese propaganda
yes that absolutely that absolutely did
happen but that that's a bit of a
different topic Marcus thank you so much
for the call I'm going to move on
because I've got a bunch of people
waiting but you certainly covered a
gamut of issues and I really do uh I
really do appreciate that let's go to
Andy from Sweden Andy welcome to the
David Pacman show what's on your mind
today
and please unmute yourself Andy so that
we can hear you
hello David can you hear me yes I can
I'm a big fan for Sweden and I have a
question to you in two parts if that's
okay yeah of course uh who is your
favorite chess player that's my favorite
I I don't have a favorite chess player I
I uh I'd have to I don't know I don't
think I have just one
I don't think honestly
are you watching the world championship
I have not I have no I've been so busy
what's going is anything notable
happening
I mean it's very tight very tight right
now between nepomyachi from Russia and
dingling around from China okay I'll try
to I'll try to follow a little bit if I
can
hey so you can you can watch on
chess.com uh they have a stream right
now beautiful uh and the second part is
who do you think is the best chess
playing Washington in terms of you know
in in Congress and in the Senate I have
absolutely no idea do any of them even
play
I have no idea maybe they play 40 chess
right right okay thank you Andy from
Sweden thank you I uh very much
appreciate that let's end there and not
press our luck we will take calls again
and we will do so next week we will take
a break and be back right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into Friday feedback
where we hear uh from some of you your
messages across different platforms you
can email info davidpackman.com feel
free to leave a comment on YouTube it
might be featured here or post something
to the subreddit really whatever you
prefer first one is from Wolfie Wolfie
says Mr Pac-Man hello I've been watching
your content nearly five years since
Trump's bizarre presidency but I do have
a bizarre yeah I do have a question to
ask you I'm okay with your opinion and
I'd rather keep it between us well I
don't do that it's all either on the air
or or not at all but we'll keep you
Anonymous what is your view on lgbtq
same-sex marriage and the whole things
relating to it I am a gay male but I
think as an outcast it's totally getting
kind of corporate anyway just wanted
your opinion I mean you can share it on
YouTube but I'd rather remain anonymous
good you we are keeping you Anonymous
Wolfie could be anybody uh my views on
lgbtq same-sex marriage and all of it I
have been a staunch and Powerful Ally
for the LGBT community for as long as
I've been doing this show
I've been an advocate for gay marriage
for as long as I've been doing this show
these these aren't even controversial or
contentious issues for me
um and we have been
following the evolution of the political
and social narrative around those issues
for more than a decade and a half on the
show and so there are probably hundreds
of videos that I have done on the
subject there are also for newer viewers
or or listeners of the show
at least a couple dozen interviews that
I've done over the years with overt
rancid homophobes of different kinds and
flavors and sorts and more recently as
I'm sure people who have been following
the political discourse are aware
in the United States
the homophobes have shifted towards
transphobia and focusing on the trans
Community you know there's a movement on
the right which loves to say
there is no more
hyper-represented group in the United
States then LGBT folks you've got a you
know a pride flag at the United Nations
there's Pride parades there's uh
everything gay pride month this is a
group that is so overrepresented
relative to their size in the population
you know the Counterpoint I would make
to that is this is a group on whom there
is so much Focus because for decades the
right just can't leave folks alone
and has activated first it was we need
to defend marriage remember when that
was the whole thing then all of a sudden
there's gay marriage we've had it for
years everything's fine nothing bad has
happened now the focus is on trans
people so to those who say it's an
over-represented movement relative to
its population
the obsession seems to be coming from
the right and from those who want to
take rights away all right Wolfie so I
hope that that's I hope it's clear and I
hope I'm uh kind of giving you a a
perspective on My Views Eleanor wrote In
from California about Maga Preppers this
is interesting Eleanor says hey David I
fell down a right-wing rabbit hole and
noticed some alarming things Maga
Twitter feeds are filled with ads for
survival gear for the end days after
they defeat the left in the Civil War
their advertising pamphlets on how to
protect yourself legally if you shoot
someone self-defense laws Etc
fascinating and terrifying at the same
time so this is this is an interesting
thing
prepping
has a religious component for some now I
want to be really clear don't email me
saying the Preppers aren't only
religious right people I know that there
is non-religious right-wing prepping and
there is also left-wing prepping I I
understand that I'm a very casual
prepper myself very casual I have like a
can of tuna under the desk taped in case
there's even an emergency I can pull it
out and just eat it I guess I'd need a
can opener but I'll deal with that later
um
but there has been a history
of religiously oriented prepping in the
Mormon faith prepping is a big thing but
also an Evangelical uh Christian circles
there's been shows like the Jim Baker
show and others Alex Jones products have
had a prepping aspect to it that is
maybe a little less overtly religiously
based but but it's still there so that's
not surprised at all what they've done
recently is they've just shifted the
reasoning
10 12 years ago a lot of it was like the
Rapture
uh you've got to be prepared for the
apocalypse and when all of that happens
you're going to want to have this food
storage now it has shifted a lot to you
know there's this Marxist dystopia that
we're heading towards where there will
be no food availability or if we have
another pandemic the Liberals will shut
down the food supply so you better have
it so the language has changed around it
but there's actually Maga prepping is
just the latest sort of outcropping or
protuberance of what is a much larger
right wing and often religiously
oriented prepping community and when
they add in the gun elements to it it is
it is certainly scary stuff Graham wrote
in and says hey David welcome back hope
you enjoyed a nice break guess your uh
your guest hosts did an excellent job as
always and Graham goes on to say
I'm sure it hasn't escaped your
attention but I noticed the following
your YouTube subscribers right before
the right wing hate mob
1.66 million your YouTube subscribers
after the right wing hate mob over
1.69 million seems that went well for
them eh exactly as I said in the
previous message the whole thing created
noise and it probably made a bunch of
new people go and check out your channel
thinking to themselves this guy seems
like a rare sensible voice and end up
subscribing I know it's been painful
from the standpoint of advertisers but I
find it difficult not to be amused by
how poorly this worked out for the mob
yeah listen I've said to people the
entire tweet Scandal regarding my tweet
about the Nashville shooting and prayer
and it getting all the way to Donald
Trump Jr posting about me and Candace
Owens and others David Pacman does not
have a soul yes all right it would have
been uniquely good were it not for the
fact that people started harassing my
dad and other people online right and
the the death threats and all of it it
would have been uniquely good
now that everybody's forgotten about it
a lot of the good is left we've got like
40 000 new subscribers on YouTube and we
had like a thousand people signed up for
paid subscriptions on the website all of
that
um but yeah Graham is Right which is to
some degree this backfired on the right
wing mob let's look at our subreddit
user radage posted I find it funny how
failed former president Trump is touting
Florida as third worst in the country
for many things in his so-called
statement stating how Florida is third
worst in coveted cases third worst in
covet deaths third worst in crimes
doesn't that strike anyone as no wonder
since Florida is the third most populous
state in the nation and no relevance
whatsoever that Ron De Santa monius was
governor does he really think his
followers are that dumb to take his
claims without a grain of salt well yeah
his followers are accepting those claims
without questioning them the reality
about Florida is a very mediocre story
now I know people will write to me I'll
say but David you go to Florida all the
time and you talk about how great it is
I enjoy certain parts of Florida that is
absolutely true I also am aware of the
real coveted numbers in Florida
per capita when you look at covid
numbers per capita in Florida adjusted
to the population
Florida's very mediocre it's not nearly
the worst death rate and it's not nearly
the lowest death rate it's not nearly
the worst case rate or that it's just a
mediocre State overall in many ways
there are parts of Florida that are
doing well and parts of Florida that are
doing less well
but economically as far as education
goes as far as all these things Florida
is very mediocre and what's funny is
Trump used to talk about how great
Florida was when he wanted to talk about
how the the approach to the pandemic
from right-wing States was better now
he's saying Florida is terrible it's the
same Florida it's just Trump's telling a
different story about it from the
YouTube channel YouTube user Douglas
ducote clown says Maga now stands for my
ass got arrested which is funny but then
another user protest 2A which I can only
imagine means Second Amendment
has a blistering conspiracy theory about
the Trump arrest this user says he was
not arrested didn't ride in a cop car
didn't get handcuffed Dems just made the
biggest mistake because they got nothing
on him it's already backfiring we'll see
well yeah we will see that is a wild
conspiracy theory that there really was
no arrest of course there was there are
real fair questions as to what will
happen in the polling thanks to the
arrest it seems it's a little helpful
for Trump in the Republican primary but
probably damaging in the general
election if Trump makes it that far but
we will see but Trump didn't really get
arrested as really something else one
other note about the Trump arrest and
this is a really good point Spicy Dragon
posted quote I guess New York City isn't
so big and scariest to keep the
Republicans away true a bunch of these
Republicans who always talk about how
dangerous New York City is
swarmed into the city for Trump's arrest
ask how many of them were terrified or
attacked while here did any of them
actually go and show crime I'm a
lifelong New York City girl and have
never been attacked mugged or murdered
yet as far as I know LOL yeah I mean
listen my experience in New York City is
regularly one where I never even see
crime obviously big cities have crime uh
what is important of course is what are
the crime rates how do the crime rates
uh separate from or contrast with the
narrative about democratically Led
cities are the most dangerous we know
that's not true we know about the red
State murder problem we know about all
of these things but it is interesting
that there was not a single story all of
these Trump supporters who came into New
York City for the arrest not a single
story of even witnessing a crime never
never mind even being the victim of such
a crime and remember the crime rate
including property crime and violent
crime is higher in Oklahoma City than it
is in New York City those are the facts
they're not very convenient for many on
the right all right we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com when you do that you
really do get access to the bonus show
instantly oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
very much so use the coupon code 24
starts now we'll see you on the bonus
show or otherwise I'll be back with you
on Monday
foreign